pour cette journée nationale de la
déportation le président de la
république qui avait donc dû choisi
d'inaugurer la maison des enfants
d'izieu
pour sabine zlatin sa fondatrice le chef
de l'état a tenu sa promesse faire
d'izieu un lieu de mémoire nationale
deux mille personnes ont assisté dans le
recueillement à cette cérémonie
l'hommage de la république française aux
douze mille enfants juifs déportés par
les nazis avec la complicité du
gouvernement de vichy en inscrivant la
rénovation de la maison d'izieu au
programme des grands travaux du
septennat françois mitterrand a voulu
faire de ce lieu un symbole du crime
contre l'humanité izieu un symbole un
lieu de mémoire mais aussi
d'enseignement d'éducation civique doit
ainsi être réhabilités dans l'école
républicaine
la justice rendue ou à rendre ne nous
exempte pas du principal c'est-à-dire de
la lutte quotidienne contre les germes
d'un mal qui guette nos sociétés c'est à
l'école que se tissent les liens de
solidarité qui font un peuple
c'était l'école que se forge l'esprit de
tolérance c'est à l'école où commence la
lutte contre toute forme d'exclusion est
d'abord celle du champ de la race 2000
personnes ont assisté dans le
recueillement à cette cérémonie d'une
grande émotion
inauguration du musée mémorial à
l'occasion de la journée de la
déportation donnent tout leur sens aux
mots mémoire et réconciliation nationale
dans la conciliation qui se fonde sur
l'oubli n'est ni durable
livrets à tandis que la réconciliation
qui est fondée sur la mémoire sur la
reconnaissance de l'événement toute
vente voilà ce qui s'est passé voilà ce
que nous avons fait je crois de la
mémoire le constitue l'un des événements
là des moyens de préserver le pays
d'autres dérives dans l'avenir et c'est
cela me semble que la leçon de la
journée d'aujourd'hui izieu est ainsi
entré dans l'histoire de la république